* Sanfte Musik *
In diesem Film geht es um die Liebe
und unsere Vorstellungen davon.
In diesem Film geht es auch
um unsere Sehnsüchte und Träume.
Und darum, was wir daraus machen.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wieso heiraten wir?
Für mich ist es
eine traditionelle Sache.
Als Frau ist es auch ein Traum.
Weil wir uns lieben.
- Ja.
Die monogame Beziehung hat in unserer
Gesellschaft einen hohen Stellenwert,
und die Treue steht in Beziehungen
ganz oben auf der Liste.
Laut anonymen Umfragen geht aber
rund jede zweite Schweizerin,
jeder zweite Schweizer fremd.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Von den Paaren,
die in die Therapie kommen,
thematisieren im Vorfeld 50-60 %
das Thema Untreue.
Das ist ein wichtiges Thema.
Viele meinen,
Fremdgehen habe damit zu tun,
dass es in der Beziehung
nicht mehr stimmt.
Dass Wunsch und Realität
so weit auseinandergehen,
gab mir zu denken, und ich beschloss,
den Fragen rund um Liebe und Treue,
Sexualität und Abenteuerlust
nachzugehen.
In diesen zwei Jahren,
in denen du fremdgehst,
und nebenbei Geschichten hast:
Sind das zwei, vier, zehn oder 20?
(Stimme, verfremdet)
Es sind vielleicht so ...
... 15-20, würde ich sagen.
Die du gedatet hast
oder mit denen du im Bett warst?
Mit denen ich im Bett war.
Es waren längere Sachen dabei,
aber auch One-Night-Stands.
Als mir Lena zum ersten Mal von ihren
Seitensprüngen erzählte, staunte ich.
So hatte ich das bisher
noch nie gehört:
dass man
in einer festen Beziehung lebt
und über Jahre mit verschiedenen
Männern heimliche Affären hat.
Die Geschichte von Lena
machte mich neugierig
und ich wollte wissen,
wie es dazu kam.
Ich war
in einer langjährigen Beziehung.
Wir haben immer wieder
darüber geredet, was Treue bedeutet.
Dabei kam heraus, dass Treue
für mich kein wichtiger Wert ist.
Loyalität ist mir sehr wichtig.
Aber ich verstehe Loyalität nicht
unbedingt als etwas Körperliches,
sondern emotional, geistig.
Nach vielen Jahren
hatte ich irgendwann das Gefühl,
dass ich noch
etwas anderes sehen möchte.
Eigentlich habe ich ...
... im klassischen Sinne
Affären gesucht.
Im Sinne davon, dass ich
mit jemandem Sex erleben möchte.
Ich möchte für diese Person
aber auch etwas empfinden.
Eine Art emotionales Abenteuer.
Das Terrain, auf welchem
ich mich bewege, ist heikel.
Dass sich meine Protagonistinnen
und Protagonisten
nicht alle zeigen können,
liegt auf der Hand.
Wenn sie zu Hause auffliegen, könnten
ganze Lebensentwürfe einstürzen.
Bei Ben wären neben seiner langjäh-
rigen Ehe auch drei Kinder betroffen.
Deshalb beantwortet er meine Fragen
per SMS, über Tage hinweg.
* Benachrichtigungston *
"Was ist der Reiz am Seitensprung?"
"Das Neue, unbedingt,
der Reiz des Neuen."
"Die erste Berührung,
der erste Kuss,
das erste Mal die Hand im Höschen,
wie riecht sie, wie fühlt sich
ihre Haut an, was tut sie danach -
das sind ganze Lebensgeschichten
in einem Zeitraffer."
"Ausserdem: Man lernt doch
mit einem neuen Menschen
immer auch noch
neue Dinge kennen."
"Neue Wohnungen,
neue Bars, Restaurants, Hotels."
"Man hat vielleicht
einen anderen Blick auf eine Stadt."
"Selbstverständlich geht es auch
um Sex - aber eben nicht nur."
* Hoffnungsvolle Violinenklänge *
Der Wunsch, eines Tages
der ganz grossen Liebe zu begegnen
und mit diesem Menschen
durchs Leben zu gehen,
schlummert in vielen von uns.
Auch Mia träumte diesen Traum.
Ich stellte mir vor,
dass ich einen Mann finde,
wir glücklich sind, heiraten
und eine Familie gründen.
Dass wir miteinander wachsen können.
Ich bin nicht davon ausgegangen,
dass es nur von kurzer Dauer ist
und gleich wieder
von jemandem zerstört wird.
Irgendjemand, das war Mia selbst.
Seit zehn Jahren ist sie verheiratet,
arbeitet in einer Führungsposition
und hat zwei kleine Kinder.
Mit der Zeit habe man sich
in der Ehe auseinander gelebt.
Und plötzlich war da
ein alter Bekannter,
der um sie warb
und ihr geben konnte, was sie suchte.
Bei mir -
das klingt sehr romantisierend ...
Die Erotik
kam immer an zweiter Stelle.
Ich war nicht sehr erfüllt
in der Beziehung, die ich hatte.
Ich suchte vielmehr jemanden,
der mich so sieht, wie ich bin.
Der wirklich interessiert ist.
Alles drumherum,
Gespräche, SMS, Mails
hatten bei mir immer einen
höheren Stellenwert als der Sex.
* Triumphale Klänge *
Hochzeitsmesse in Bern.
Zum 20. Mal findet hier
die Hochzeitsmesse MariNatal statt.
Während zweieinhalb Tagen
wird in den Messehallen die
traditionelle Hochzeit zelebriert.
Dreimal täglich
werden in einer Modenschau
eine Auswahl an Brautkleidern,
Anzüge für den Bräutigam
sowie Festmode
für die Hochzeitsgäste gezeigt.
Das Angebotsspektrum
ist schier unendlich.
Es präsentieren sich Hochzeitsmusiker
neben Torten.
Vom Oldtimer über die Tischdeko bis
hin zu den Trauringen gibt es alles,
was es braucht, um den schönsten
Tag im Leben eines Paares zu feiern.
Ich möchte mit ihm das Leben
verbringen. Ja.
Ja.
Für mich war es v.a.
eine traditionelle Frage.
Man besiegelt die Liebe
und bestätigt sie gegen aussen.
Es gibt einem
ein Gefühl von Sicherheit.
Ich habe mich entschieden, den Rest
meines Lebens mit ihr zu verbringen.
Sie ist die Frau, die ich möchte,
die mir alles geben kann.
Für mich bedeuten Beziehung und Ehe
gegenseitiges Vertrauen.
Das soll so bleiben. Man soll sich
eine Familie aufbauen können.
Glücklich und zufrieden miteinander.
Dass man nicht aufhört,
an der Beziehung zu arbeiten.
Wir waren jung,
als wir uns kennenlernten
und sind zusammen
erwachsen geworden.
Jetzt werden wir zusammen alt.
Wenn man zueinander Ja sagt,
dann sagt man Ja zur Ewigkeit.
Ich finde das
einen schönen Gedanken.
Mit Ups und Downs.
- Mhm.
An die 40'000 Paare
gaben sich hierzulande
im vergangenen Jahr das Ja-Wort.
Rund 39 % dieser Ehen
werden durchschnittlich
nach 15 Jahren wieder geschieden.
Inwiefern die Untreue
in diesem Ganzen eine Rolle spielt,
interessierte mich.
Über 10 Mio. Ergebnisse
präsentiert mir die Suchmaschine
zum Thema Seitensprung.
Ranglisten, wo ich
die besten Seitensprungpartner finde,
werben mit Slogans wie
"Gönn dir eine Affäre".
Datingplattformen machen mir
das Fremdgehen schmackhaft.
Alles casual:
Man verabredet sich ungezwungen
zu gelegentlichem Sex.
Egal ob verheiratet,
gebunden oder single.
In der Werbung
sind sehr schöne Leute,
es hat überhaupt nichts
Schmuddeliges.
Man hat das Gefühl,
auch Teil dieser schönen,
attraktiven Leute sein zu wollen,
die sich hier auf eine
kultivierte Art und Weise paaren.
* Lachen *
Es geht in diese Richtung.
Wie viel Einfluss haben
diese Casual-Plattformen
auf uns und unsere Beziehungen?
Guy Bodenmann kennt sich
mit Geschichten dieser Art aus.
Der Paarforscher,
Therapeut und Buchautor
hat inzwischen auch
das Thema Online-Untreue
und seine Auswirkungen
auf Paarbeziehungen untersucht.
Es gibt zwei markante Veränderungen:
Es ist einfacher, untreu zu sein,
weil man über die Plattformen
die Möglichkeit hat.
Egal, wo man ist, kann man schauen,
wo es potenzielle Partner
für ein sexuelles Abenteuer gibt.
Damit wurde der Schritt zur Untreue
sehr viel einfacher.
Die andere Dimension ist:
Was ist Untreue überhaupt?
Bisher war die Untreue
definiert als sexuelle Untreue,
v.a. koitale Untreue.
Mit diesen heutigen Plattformen
gibt es die starke Tendenz
zur emotionalen Untreue.
Wenn jemand plötzlich mit einer
anderen Person intensiv chattet,
emotionale, sexuelle Inhalte
und Fantasien austauscht.
Dort stellt sich die Frage:
Was ist treu, was untreu?
Das ist ein fliessender Übergang.
Das sind neue Phänomene,
die man früher nicht kannte.
* Beunruhigende Klänge *
* Benachrichtigungston *
"Ich glaube, die virtuellen
Möglichkeiten haben das Sexualleben
und vielleicht sogar unser
Verhältnis zur Wahrheit verändert."
"Gut, der Seitensprung
ist wohl so alt wie der Sex selbst -
aber die Auswahl, die Vielfalt
und auch das Tempo
sind ganz anders geworden."
"Einfacher ist es geworden."
"Es ist nicht mehr nötig, das
Lächeln an der Bar deuten zu können,
was irgendwie schade ist."
"Viel schneller geht es:
eine SMS, 1 Std. Zeit,
und hopp, ab in die Kiste."
"Obwohl - ich habe auf diese Art
wunderbare Frauen kennengelernt,
von deren Existenz
ich wohl nie erfahren hätte,
gäbe es Facebook,
Tinder und Co. nicht."
"Es ist ja auch nicht falsch."
"Gerade der schriftliche Austausch
kann hervorragend sein."
"Bis man all das im Gespräch
erfahren könnte,
würden wohl Monate vergehen."
"Es ist ja auch einfacher,
über seine sexuellen Vorlieben
und Wünsche zu schreiben
als darüber zu reden,
dort an besagter Bar,
nach besagtem, allenfalls
richtig gedeutetem Lächeln."
"Selbstverständlich ist bei Weitem
nicht alles Gold, was glänzt."
"Die Selbstdarstellung
in der virtuellen Welt
passt bei vielen Menschen
nicht zur Realität,
aber das ist ja
im richtigen Leben auch so."
"Und am Ende ist da immer:
the real thing."
"Die Chemie, die stimmen muss."
* Der Motor wird gestartet. *
* Ruhige Klänge *
Der Vorteil von mir und anderen
Frauen auf der Plattform ist,
dass wir
in der grossen Minderheit sind.
Für mich war es eine Art El Dorado.
Das sind keine Ladenhüter.
Man soll nicht denken,
dass die im realen Leben
keine abkriegen würden.
Im Gegenteil.
Die meisten sind schon länger
in einer Beziehung
und aus irgendeinem Grund -
entweder, es sind Kinder da,
und man wartet, bis die grösser
sind, bevor man eigene Wege geht.
Oder, sie fühlen sich wohl in
der Beziehung, aber es fehlt etwas.
Die meisten sind sehr froh,
dass ich liiert bin,
dann gibt es
keine Komplikationen.
Wenn man mit den Männern redet,
sagen sie oft,
dass ihr Kriterium für ein Treffen
eine liierte Frau sei.
Damit diese nicht irgendwelche
Ansprüche an sie stellen können.
Und die Frau es noch herausfindet.
Die Angst aufzufliegen
ist bei den Männern sehr gross.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Wer sich einen Seitensprung
organisieren konnte,
ist noch nicht unbedingt am Ziel -
denn oft fehlt das Liebesnest.
Doch die Branche hat auch hier längst
das passende Angebot gefunden.
Auf seitensprungzimmer.ch
finden Willige in der Deutschschweiz
über 90 Zimmer und Studios,
in welchen sie sich
heimlich treffen können.
Erwin Anderhub
ist der Betreiber der Webseite.
Hereinspaziert!
Ja.
Bett.
Fernseher mit Videorecorder,
DVD-Player.
Hier haben wir eine kleine Küche
mit Snacks, Kaffemaschine,
Kühlschrank mit Getränken.
Hier kann sich jeder unserer Gäste
bedienen.
Ja.
Hier kann man sich setzen,
falls man zuerst reden möchte.
Hier hat es Kondome, falls nötig.
Die stellen wir
gratis zur Verfügung.
Hier hat es etwas zum Fesseln,
falls man auf so etwas steht.
Die ersten Buchungen
sind um 8 oder 9 Uhr morgens.
Wir haben relativ viel Buchungen
über den Mittag.
Auch am Nachmittag und Abend.
Übernachtungen haben wir fast nie.
Denn jeder muss ja
irgendwann wieder nach Hause.
Gibt es Spitzentage?
Ja, unter der Woche
läuft mehr als am Wochenende.
Noch nicht am Montagmorgen,
aber ab Montagnachmittag
bis Freitagabend
ist es mehr oder weniger
ausgeglichen.
Am Wochenende weniger,
am Sonntag ganz wenige.
In der Ferienzeit
läuft es auch nicht wahnsinnig gut.
Entweder, sind sie dann
wirklich in den Ferien
oder sie sind eine Woche zu Hause,
gehen nicht arbeiten
und können nicht wegschleichen.
Das spüren wir schon ein wenig.
Die Zimmer,
die Erwin Anderhub vermietet,
können anonym gebucht
und besucht werden.
Dies sei wohl auch, was
seine Kundschaft besonders schätze.
Ich hatte früher viele Leute,
die mir sagten,
dass das Zimmer, das sie
alle zwei, drei Wochen buchten,
wie ein zweites Zuhause sei.
Dort fühlen sie sich wohl, haben
Ruhe und einen geschützten Rahmen.
Das sei für sie
wie ein zweites Zuhause.
Sind das Stammkunden
oder gibt es grosse Wechsel?
Es gibt Leute,
die kommen immer wieder.
Es gibt Kunden, die kommen einmal
in der Woche oder einmal im Monat.
Dann kommen welche drei-
oder viermal innerhalb kurzer Zeit.
Plötzlich nicht mehr,
dann hat sich vielleicht
etwas an der Situation geändert.
Nach einem halben Jahr merkt man,
dass er wieder kommt.
Vorher hat es gepiepst, ich muss
schnell schauen, sie buchen per SMS.
Ich habe meine SMS-Vorlage.
Da muss ich nur schnell klicken
und schicken ... und erledigt.
Gut, ja.
Wie gelingt es den Leuten,
ihre geheimen Treffen und Abenteuer
über Monate am anderen Leben
vorbei zu schleusen, frage ich mich.
Und ebenso, wie man sich
das zurechtlegt im Kopf.
Unabhängig von der innigen
Partnerschaft, die wir haben,
möchte ich noch einen Teil
für mich leben.
Ohne meinen Partner.
Das muss etwas sein,
das nur mir gehört.
Das macht die Spannung
des Ganzen aus.
Man kann vielleicht sagen ...
... dass es sich
aufregender anfühlt,
eine Art Doppelleben zu führen.
Ein Leben zu führen, in dem nur ich
in das Ganze eingeweiht bin.
* Benachrichtigungston *
"Weiter:
Wie legt man sich das zurecht?"
"Ich weiss nicht,
wie das bei anderen ist,
aber ich lebe
da in einer Parallelwelt."
"Ich überlege mir in diesem Moment
nicht wirklich,
was ich meiner Partnerin antue."
"Wenn ich mich ganz auf die
Seitensprung-Partnerin konzentriere,
dann findet mein Leben
genau dort statt."
"Für mich ist das auch
eine Flucht aus dem Alltag."
"Keine Steuererklärungen ausfüllen,
kein Ärger mit den Mitarbeitern,
keine kranke Katze."
"Ja,
das sind oft auch Lügengebilde -
doch allein schon deren Konstruktion
ist eine oftmals
wunderbare geistige Herausforderung,
etwas so ganz anderes als "Tatort"
am Sonntagabend
oder Brunch
bei der Schwiegermutter."
"Erstaunlich ist dabei:
Ein schlechtes Gewissen
habe ich erst in dem Moment,
wenn die Tür hinter mir zufällt
und ich mich auf den Heimweg mache."
"Vorher: keine Sekunde."
* Drollige Musik *
In Gegensatz zu Lena und Ben
macht Mia das Doppelleben
und Versteckspiel zu schaffen.
Die ganze Geheimnistuerei,
Lügerei, das Versteckspiel ...
Das wird auch oft in Filmen
und Büchern beschrieben,
dass das etwas Prickelndes
und Spannendes sei.
Dass es den Reiz ausmacht.
Für mich war das ...
... nicht so.
Es hat mich belastet,
ich fand es unwürdig.
Das Merkwürdige daran ist,
dass ich mir selbst
extrem untreu wurde,
wenn ich an meine Seitensprünge
zurück denke.
Man lügt die ganze Zeit.
Am Anfang
sucht man irgendwelche Alibis.
Man hat Skrupel
und ein schlechtes Gewissen
und Gewissensbisse.
Je mehr man darin ist, umso leichter
fällt jede weitere Lüge.
Es gehört dann fest dazu.
Beim doppelten Spiel
war das Schlimmste,
dass ich mich
von mir entfremdet habe.
Wenn's schwierig wird
in Dreiecksgeschichten,
tritt Maya Onken auf den Plan.
Sie hat ein Buch zum Thema
geschrieben
und führt seit zehn Jahren
SOS-Affäre,
eine Beratungsstelle für Menschen
in Dreieckskonstellationen.
Alle drei Positionen
haben grosse Nöte, aber andere.
Die geliebte Position
ist immer Nummer 2,
sie muss immer warten,
ist auf einer Warteposition.
Das kann einen fertigmachen.
An den Festtagen
ist man ganz deutlich Nummer 2.
Wenn die verheiratete Frau
oder der verheiratete Mann
immer Nummer 1 ist, dann kann das
einem mit der Zeit extrem zusetzen
und am Selbstwert nagen,
das ist dieses Leiden.
Ein Betrogener
hat innerliche Wunden,
weil seine oder ihre Visionen von
Ehe und Beziehung zerstört wurden.
Aber auch Seitenspringer
haben einen Riesenstress,
weil sie alles
unter einen Hut bringen müssen
und in verschiedenen Leben
umherspringen,
ohne auf das andere Leben
hinzuweisen.
Die haben immer ein hohes Energie-
level und stehen unter Stress,
dass sie nicht auffliegen.
Offenbar, ist es nicht einfach,
über Jahre in einer
monogamen Beziehung zu leben.
Dennoch hat sich die Monogamie
weitgehend durchgesetzt.
Gefestigt wird sie bis heute
durch soziale,
religiöse und moralische Normen.
Schwören wir also unseren Partner-
innen und Partnern ewige Treue,
obwohl das
unserer Natur widerspricht?
Sind wir monogam?
Oder zwängen wir uns nur
in ein gesellschaftliches Korsett?
Wenn man bei den Säugetieren
und Affen schaut,
gibt es ursprünglich
eine sehr geringe Monogamierate.
Bei den Affen sind es 25 %,
bei den Säugetieren 3 %.
Man hat relativ wenig,
die wirklich monogam veranlagt sind,
wenn man es
rein evolutionär betrachtet.
Der Mensch als Nachkomme des Affen
hat eine geringe Wahrscheinlichkeit
für Monogamie.
Das ist das sexuelle System.
Rein sexuell macht Monogamie
keinen Sinn.
V.a. in den Urzeiten des Menschen
ging es darum,
sich möglichst breit
zu reproduzieren,
damit man das Überleben der
menschlichen Spezies sichern konnte.
Das andere System,
das Bindungssystem -
das man sehr stark braucht,
man muss geliebt werden -,
spielte früher keine Rolle
im Sinne von zwei Menschen zusammen.
Die Sterblichkeitsrate
war viel zu hoch,
es ging um das Gruppengefüge.
Im heutigen Zeitalter verweben sich
Bindung und Sexualität.
Damit wird das Ganze hochkomplex.
Die Frage, ob der Mensch
für die Monogamie gemacht ist,
kann man sexuell gesehen mit
"eigentlich nicht" beantworten,
Bindungsmässig ja.
* Benachrichtigungston *
"Weiter geht's mit den Klischees:"
"Sucht man Sex ausserhalb, wenn's
in der Beziehung nicht mehr klappt?"
"Schwierige Frage."
"Der Sex in einer
langen Beziehung tendiert doch dazu,
sehr häufig nach dem gleichen Muster
abzulaufen -
und dass Mann/Frau dann vielleicht
etwas Abwechslung sucht,
ist doch irgendwie verständlich."
"Die Bedürfnisse können sich
auseinanderentwickeln."
"Dazu kommt,
dass ich bei meiner Gattin
gar nicht das Bedürfnis verspüre,
andere Spielformen auszuprobieren."
"Irgendwie gar nicht will,
dass sie kein Höschen trägt,
damit ich sie 5 Sek., nachdem die
Haustür ins Schloss gefallen ist,
auf dem Küchentisch vögeln kann."
"Was aber - und dessen
bin ich mir durchaus bewusst -
auch an meiner eigenen
Kleinbürgerlichkeit liegen könnte."
* Lachen *
Charlie. lass mich, Charlie.
Oder ist es vielleicht so, dass Sei-
tenspringerinnen und Seitenspringer
gar nicht auf der Suche
nach einem Gegenüber sind,
sondern vielmehr
auf der Suche nach sich selbst?
Neue Sachen auszuprobieren,
egal ob Sexualität, oder sonst,
ist etwas Wunderbares
an einer Affäre.
Es bietet die Chance,
sich selbst neu zu erfinden.
Man kann sich anders geben,
egal ob im Bett oder als Mensch.
Das bietet sich im Leben wenig,
sich nochmals neu zu erfinden.
Bei einer Affäre kann man
andere Facetten von sich zeigen
oder sie betonen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Der Anspruch, dass ein Mensch
über 50 Jahre hinweg,
alle unsere Bedürfnisse befriedigen
und abdecken kann, ist hoch.
Und vielleicht ist die Idee,
dass es in der Sexualität
immer stimmig ist und bleibt
tatsächlich zu romantisierend.
Je länger der Sexualpartner
der Gleiche ist,
umso mehr gibt es
eine sog. Verstärkererosion.
Das sexuell Neue ist immer attrak-
tiver als das sexuell Bekannte.
Das ist Visuell und auf der
ganzen Ebene ein bekanntes Phänomen.
Dass die Sexualität einschläft,
ist bei den meisten Paaren der Fall.
Bei denen mit Kindern
beschleunigter,
Paare ohne Kinder
sind genauso betroffen,
weil die Variation und das Beleben
der Sexualität sehr häufig fehlt.
Dort müsste man ansetzen
in der Prävention.
Es ginge in langjährigen Beziehungen
also darum,
sich als Paar
immer wieder Freiräume zu schaffen,
um sich auch sexuell
gemeinsam weiterzuentwickeln.
Stattdessen
lassen sich liierte Partner
immer öfter auf Online-Chats ein
und pflegen Beziehungen
in der virtuellen Welt.
Teils sitzen sie in der gleichen
Wohnung in verschiedenen Zimmern
und der eine liest ein Buch
oder schaut fern
und der andere chattet nebenan
mit einer fremden Person.
Das führt auch zu einer Entfremdung.
Anstatt die Zeit füreinander
zu nutzen, wird die Energie -
und die rare Zeit
in unserer heutigen Gesellschaft -
nicht in die Partnerschaft
investiert,
sondern mit einer fremden Person
geteilt.
Ganz häufig
ist die emotionale Exklusivität
noch fast etwas wichtiger
als die sexuelle.
Wobei das vermischt ist.
Entsprechend kann es
nicht mehr schön getrennt werden.
Die Gefahr, dass,
wenn der andere sexuell untreu wird,
er einen verlassen
und nicht mehr lieben könnte,
die ganze Bindung
infrage gestellt wird,
macht das Ganze so explosiv.
Auch die Sexualforscherin
Andrea Burri befasst sich seit Jahren
mit den Themen rund um Liebe,
Treue und Sexualität.
Weshalb fürchten sich so viele
vor der sexuellen Untreue
des geliebten Menschen?
Wenn man sich sexuell
auf jemanden einlässt
bindet das eher.
Dadurch kann auch mehr entstehen.
Folglich hat man Angst,
dass daraus mehr entstehen könnte,
wenn sich zwei Menschen
auf dieser Ebene begegnen.
D.h., die Leute haben Verlustangst?
Ich denke schon.
Viele Leute können Sex und Beziehung
nach wie vor nicht trennen.
Wobei man sich immer fragen muss,
weshalb können sie es nicht?
Können sie es wirklich nicht,
oder ist das wieder vorgegeben?
Eine glückliche, treue Ehe
heisst sexuelle Treue.
Viele kommen nicht
aus diesem Konzept heraus,
dass es doch gehen würde.
Sie denken gar nicht weiter.
Sie möchten den Gedanken
auch nicht zu Ende bringen.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Weitergedacht und die traditionelle
Monogamie hinter sich gelassen
haben Peti und Franziska.
Sie sind seit zehn Jahren verheiratet
und haben für sich
die ideale Beziehungsform gefunden.
Es ist offen und frei,
jeder darf machen, was er will.
Sie darf ...
Zum Nachbarn und erst übermorgen
wieder nach Hause kommen.
Was auch immer. Wir schauen,
dass es dem anderen gut geht.
Aber ...
Wenn man dem anderen
nicht vorschreiben muss,
was er zu tun hat -
weil er selbst entscheiden darf,
was er tun möchte -
ist es viel schöner,
als wenn man beschränkt wird.
Ohne Regeln.
Eine Beziehung ohne Regeln,
in der alles sein kann und darf.
In der man es dem anderen gönnt,
wenn es ihm gut geht,
weil man ihn liebt.
Liebe.
Das grosse Wort, das magische Gefühl.
Wie definieren wir Liebe?
Für viele hat sie
etwas mit Exklusivitätsrecht
oder sogar mit Besitz zu tun.
Für Peti und Franziska
hat Liebe viel mit Freiheit zu tun.
Regeln haben wir fast keine,
einfach ...
... immer ehrlich sein,
alles auf den Tisch.
Mit jemand fremdem
ein Kondom benutzen,
das sind die einzigen Regeln.
Für mich ist das ein ganz ...
Die Basis für das Ganze ist,
dass alles klar und offen ist.
Und dass Vertrauen herrscht.
Auch wenn ich mit einem anderen Mann
eine schöne Begegnung habe,
kann ich alles mit ihm teilen.
Manche sagen, dass man sich
ja nicht verlieben darf.
Wie soll man das machen?
Dann müssen wir wieder eine Mauer
bauen und die Läden runterlassen.
Dann verliebt man sich nicht.
Sobald man dafür offen ist,
kann das passieren.
Wer liebt, lässt den anderen frei.
Diese Forderung kam Ende der 60er-
Jahre von den linken Intellektuellen.
Die Hippiebewegung
verachtete jede Einschränkung
und wollte das kleinbürgerliche
Besitzdenken überwinden.
Was könnten die Gründe sein,
weshalb sich die Idee
der freien Liebe nicht verbreitet
und die sexuelle Befreiung
nicht weiterentwickelt hat?
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass es um die Einzigartigkeit geht,
die jeder Mensch haben möchte:
Ich will die Nummer 1 sein
für meinen Partner.
Ich will nicht 1,2 sein oder
meinen Platz mit jemandem teilen.
Diese Einzigartigkeit
verwechseln Leute oft mit Liebe.
Deshalb hat es immer noch
einen so hohen Stellenwert.
Was ich sagen kann:
Ich kenne sehr wenige Paare,
die eine offene Beziehung verein-
baren können und es funktioniert.
Der Wunsch nach
Einzigartigkeit und Exklusivität
könnte mit unserem Ur-Bedürfnis
nach Bindung und Sicherheit
zusammenhängen.
Bevor sich Peti und Franziska
begegneten,
lebten beide über Jahre
in traditionellen, monogamen Ehen.
Aus diesen Verbindungen
haben beide auch erwachsene Kinder.
Ein Thema, dem sie in der Vergangen-
heit immer wieder begegnet sind,
ist die Eifersucht.
Über die Eifersucht haben sie
inzwischen einiges herausgefunden.
Wenn ich eifersüchtig bin,
dann habe ich selbst das Gefühl,
nicht genug zu sein.
Er könnte weglaufen,
ich könnte ihn verlieren -
um Gottes willen!
Ich glaube, das hat mit Selbstliebe
und Selbstwert zu tun.
"Jetzt geht sie mit dem,
und er ist toller und besser
und hat das bessere Auto."
So ein Blödsinn.
Kommt nie Angst auf,
dass mal einer besser ist?
Was macht man, wenn sie aufkommt?
Was macht man, wenn einem ein Stern
auf den Kopf fällt?
Das gehört zum Spiel.
Man kann sich entweder
einzäunen und einmauern -
dann passiert gar nichts, dann kann
man gleich den Deckel bestellen,
dann passiert wirklich nichts.
Oder wenn man lebendig
und offen sein möchte,
dann kann Gutes, Schlechtes
und Unvorhergesehenes kommen,
man kann sich nicht wappnen,
es gehört alles dazu.
Offenbar lässt sich
in diesem Haushalt
niemand von Verlustängsten
irritieren.
Und irgendwie hat das wohl wirklich
mit einem gesunden Selbstwert zu tun.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin das
Beste, was ihm passieren konnte.
Das ist so ein allgegenwärtiges
Grundvertrauen, das ich habe.
Wenn er sich mal in eine Jüngere
verliebt hat, merke ich das daran,
wie er es mir erzählt: "Du klingst,
als ob du dich verliebt hast."
"Meinst du?"
"Ja, so wie du von ihr schwärmst."
Ja ...
Bis jetzt war die Angst
noch nicht da, dass er gehen könnte.
Das könnte jederzeit passieren,
ob verheiratet oder nicht.
Man kann seinen Partner
immer verlieren.
Im Gegenteil! Je mehr man versucht,
ihn an sich zu fesseln,
umso weiter
stösst man ihn von sich weg.
So geht es mir jedenfalls.
Je mehr mich jemand einengt, desto
mehr brauche ich meine Freiheit.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Nach dem Besuch
bei Peti und Franziska,
frage ich mich einmal mehr,
inwiefern das Dogma der monogamen
Beziehung wirklich Sinn macht -
da sich rund 50 % der Leute
sowieso nicht daran halten können.
Hierzu schaltet sich auch Ben
wieder mal ein.
* Benachrichtigungston *
"Unsere gesellschaftlichen Normen,
inklusive Exklusivrechten,
sind von christlichen
Vorstellungen geprägt."
"Die sind, wie wir aus 2000 Jahren
Geschichte wissen, schleierhaft."
"Entschuldige, wenn ich da allfällig
gegen deine Gesinnungen schreibe."
"Es mag egoistisch klingen,
doch am Schluss sind wir
für unser eigenes Glück zuständig."
"Natürlich
ist ein Seitensprung egoistisch,
es geht um das eigene Vergnügen."
"Doch was ist grundsätzlich
dagegen einzuwenden?"
"Auch meine Umwelt profitiert davon,
wenn ich zufrieden bin,
befriedigt, mich gut fühle."
"Weil der Seitensprung
aber die Gefühle der Umwelt,
der Partnerin verletzen kann,
bin ich eigentlich dagegen,
dass man es zu Hause erzählt -
das kommt nur äusserst selten gut."
Im Gespräch mit manchen Leuten
merke ich,
dass sie leiden
und reinen Tisch machen wollen.
Dann soll man das machen.
Dazu habe ich einen Tipp:
Wenn man reinen Tisch macht,
muss man wissen,
dass man sein Gegenüber
bis aufs Tiefste verletzt
und dass die Person,
von der man denkt,
dass man sie kennt,
in dieser Sekunde anders wird.
Ich sage den Leuten:
"Waffen aus dem Haus."
Eine Notfallnummer
ins Telefon tippen,
dass jemand in der Türe steht,
wenn der oder die ausrastet.
Es kann etwas abgehen,
das man sich nicht vorstellen kann.
* Schnalzen *
Der sollte kommen,
der Zug kommt bald.
Du weisst ja,
80 % Warten, 20 % Action.
Das ist in jedem Fall
ungefähr gleich.
Jetzt kommt er.
Er hat die Kapuze oben, der Idiot.
Ja.
- Wieso muss das sein?
Ah, siehst du tatsächlich,
das ist sie. - Aha.
Eine Schwarzhaarige. Aber eine
blonde Frau zu Hause, so läuft das!
Ja, siehst du: alle Varianten.
Ein Grossteil der Seitensprünge
fliegt früher oder später auf.
Fliegen sie nicht von selber auf,
hilft z.B. Detektiv Erich Wunderli
nach.
Sein Business lebt zu 70 %
von misstrauischen Eheleuten.
Für die Überwachung
von vermeintlich Untreuen
arbeitet er mit GPS-Trackern,
die das Bewegungsprofil von Autos
aufzeichnen.
Bevor wir Leute einsetzten,
die mit dem Auto hinterherfahren -
das ist wahnsinnig teuer,
dort sind zwei Detektive drin -
nehmen wir erst einen Monat
einen Tracker, um zu schauen,
ob wir irgendein Muster finden -
wohin geht der Mann oft?
Wo vermuten wir, geht er fremd?
Dann setzen wir diese Tracker ein,
meistens setzen wir zwei ein.
Wenn einmal
ein Tracker gefunden wird,
sucht die Person
sicher keinen zweiten Tracker.
* Ein Telefon klingelt. *
Detektei Wunderli.
Die Erfahrung zeigt uns,
dass sie am Morgen für so kurze Zeit
kaum mit einem Mann abmacht.
Wenn sie mit einem Mann abmacht,
mit dem sie ein Verhältnis hat,
braucht sie garantiert länger.
Vermutlich ist sie
mit einer Kollegin unterwegs.
Ja, ja.
Frauen sind gewieft.
Wenn sie betrügen wollen, dann so,
dass es der Mann nicht herausfindet.
Ich würde sie an Ihrer Stelle
nicht zu sehr mit Fragen löchern.
Lassen Sie sie machen.
Wenn Sie zu viel fragen,
passt sie genau auf, was sie macht.
Und was passiert,
wenn sich ein Verdacht erhärtet?
Wir sagen dem Kunden fortwährend,
was abgeht, was läuft, was passiert.
Wir schätzen neu ab,
wie wir weiter vorgehen.
Der Kunde sagt dann:
"Okay, das reicht mir,
ich möchte das Material anschauen."
Wir schicken den Leuten keine Fotos
oder Filme, wegen des Datenschutzes.
Sie müssen zu uns ins Büro kommen,
und wir zeigen auf dem Laptop
Fotos und Filmmaterial.
Das wird nicht ausgehändigt, alles
wird nach 24 Std. wieder gelöscht.
Aber sie können anhand der Bilder
Entscheidungen treffen.
Was bei Betrogenen abgeht,
wenn ein Detektiv den Verdacht
auf Untreue beweisen kann -
von diesen Geschichten haben
die meisten von uns schon gehört.
Meistens ist es die Erschütterung,
was jetzt wirklich ist,
verbunden mit der ganzen
Misstrauensgeschichte.
Wem kann ich noch Vertrauen?
Was kann ich noch ernst nehmen?
Was hat mir die Person alles
erzählt, was nicht mehr stimmt?
Der Misstrauensanteil
ist oft das Schlimmste,
nicht unbedingt
der sexuelle Fremdgeh-Akt.
Da können einige noch sagen:
"Okay, dumm gelaufen."
Aber das Emotionale und Vertrauen.
Man ist mit jemanden im gleichen
Bett und denkt auf einmal:
"Ich kenne diese Person gar nicht."
"Was hat sie mir alles erzählt
und vorgelogen?"
"Was hat sie hinter meinem Rücken
gemacht, vielleicht jahrelang?"
"Und ich habe es nicht gemerkt."
Das ist das Schlimmste.
* Düstere Klänge *
* Benachrichtigungston *
"Was ist, wenn man erwischt wird?"
"Ups, das kenne ich."
"Seit dem Festverbandelt sein
ist es mir zweimal passiert."
"Einmal las die Gattin
mein Tagebuch."
"Und kürzlich stand eine Liebhaberin
vor der Tür. Ich war nicht daheim."
"Nein, es war gar nicht gut."
"Seither hängt nicht nur
der Haussegen ziemlich schief."
"Aber an sowas denkt man nicht."
"Obwohl man müsste."
"Rein von der Wahrscheinlichkeit her
muss es hin und wieder passieren."
"Nein, nicht die Momente,
die man wirklich braucht im Leben."
Sexuelle Untreue
spiele als Scheidungsgrund häufig
eine bedeutende Rolle, lese ich.
Was hat es damit auf sich?
Und, wirkt sich der Internetzeitgeist
auf die Scheidungsrate aus?
Historisch gesehen hat die Untreue
nicht massiv zugenommen.
Das war schon immer ein Phänomen.
Heute ist es online einfacher,
früher war es mühsamer.
Wo ein Wille, da ein Weg.
Ungeachtet dessen
thematisieren 50-60 % der Paare,
die in Therapie kommen,
im Vorfeld Untreue.
Das ist ein Thema,
das häufig zur Scheidung führt.
Wenn man schaut, ob die Untreue
wirklich die Ursache ist,
dann ist es meist nicht die Ursache
sondern der Auslöser,
für die Entscheidung,
sich scheiden zu lassen.
Die Substanz
war insgesamt nicht mehr so gesund.
Auch wenn ein Seitensprung
nicht der Hauptgrund
für eine Trennung sein muss,
löst Untreue in Beziehungen
oft eine grosse Krise aus.
Um Krisen gemeinsam zu meistern,
müssten sich aber Paare über Jahre
auch gemeinsam weiterentwickeln -
und dies scheint
im Zeitalter der Selbstoptimierung
eine der grössten Herausforderungen
zu sein.
Die Paare reden nicht,
schon im Bett ist meistens Stille.
Sie sagen nicht,
was sie sich voneinander wünschen
und reden nicht über ihre
Bedürfnisse und Sehnsüchte.
Sie haben nicht gelernt,
darüber zu reden.
Quasi: "Wir lieben uns und sagen Ja
zueinander, das reicht."
Das reicht eben nicht.
Ein Paar
macht eine Entwicklung durch,
es ist frisch verliebt, dann kommt
ein Kind, der Stress mit einem Haus,
einer Hypothek, kranken Eltern.
Man kommt immer
in einen neuen Kreislauf.
Wenn man dann nicht jedes Mal sagt:
"Ich brauche das,
es ist nicht mehr gut für mich,
können wir verhandeln
und es so machen?"
Dann wird es ganz schnell unpassend,
und das Ursprungskostüm,
das geschneidert wurde,
ist sofort zu eng
und passt nicht mehr.
Dann liegt es auf der Hand,
dass jemand,
vielleicht nach jahrelanger
zu enger Kostümtortur,
die Jacke auszieht.
Mias heimliche Affäre
ist eine von unzähligen.
Was sie Menschen in ähnlichen
Situationen empfehlen würde,
wollte ich noch wissen.
Mir werden viele Geschichten
zugetragen,
gerade, weil viele wissen,
was mir passiert ist.
Ich versuche,
zuzuhören und teilzuhaben.
Ich bin dann in der Rolle
der Freundin, die sagt:
"Pass auf,
dass es dich nicht kaputtmacht."
Der einzige Ratschlag,
den ich geben kann, ist,
dass man
neben einer solchen Geschichte
sehr viel Gutes und Stabilität
im Leben haben muss.
Damit man es durchstehen kann.
Dass man abseits davon
noch ein Leben hat.
Dass es sich nicht nur
darauf fokussiert,
dass man auf die nächste Mail
oder das nächste Treffen wartet,
dass man sich nicht nur
von Treffen zu Treffen hangelt.
Sondern, dass man sein eigenes Leben
auch noch weiterlebt.
* Melancholische Streicherklänge *
* Beunruhigende Klänge *
Auch Lena hat auf ihren Streifzügen
etwas für sich herausgefunden.
Ich glaube,
richtig casual gibt es nicht,
weil man immer irgendwie
emotional hängenbleibt.
Oder die andere Person
bringt ihren eigenen Rucksack mit.
Damit muss man sich rumschlagen.
Es ist nicht nur das schöne Bild,
das man sieht, das virtuell ist.
Die Person lebt, es ist ein Mensch
aus Fleisch und Blut.
Sobald man die Person trifft,
mit all ihren Stärken und Schwächen,
dann kann es gar nicht casual sein.
Dass die Monogamie, nach wie vor
einen derart hohen Stellenwert hat,
hat mit unseren traditionellen,
moralischen Vorstellungen zu tun.
Und bestimmt auch damit,
dass es nur wenige wagen,
neue Wege auszuprobieren.
Wenn man fragt, ob Monogamie
oder Polygamie natürlich ist
oder richtig oder normal ist,
dann zielt diese Frage
auf eine einfache Antwort ab.
Diese einfache Antwort
kann man so nicht geben.
Der Mensch braucht vielleicht
eine einfache Antwort,
weil er eine Richtlinie braucht,
damit er sich
an etwas orientieren kann.
Peti und Franziska
haben für sich einen Weg gefunden,
ihre Bedürfnisse nach Nähe
und Geborgenheit
und die sexuelle Abenteuerlust
unter einen Hut zu bringen.
Ihr Beziehungsmodell ist ein Beispiel
von vielen Alternativen,
welche wir ausprobieren könnten.
Ein Rezept, wie die ideale Beziehung
generell aussehen könnte,
haben sie aber nicht.
Man kann das nicht verallgemeinern.
Für manche
mag die Monogamie gut sein,
weil es beiden guttut,
für andere eben nicht.
Der Mensch ist ein Individuum
und jeder braucht etwas anderes.
Etwas anderes zu Essen,
eine andere Art Liebe, Beziehung.
Die Kunst ist, denjenigen, der
anders lebt, nicht zu verurteilen.
Dafür, wie er das macht.
Ich würde nie jemanden ...
Im Gegenteil, wenn jemand 50 Jahre
verheiratet und noch glücklich ist -
es wiederfährt einem so selten,
dass man solche Paare erlebt.
Bei den meisten hat man das Gefühl,
dass sie nur noch
nebeneinanderher leben.
Es gibt Paare,
die nach 50 Jahren immer noch
miteinander glücklich sind. Hut ab.
Beziehung ist Arbeit.
Die haben wirklich etwas geleistet
in ihrem Leben.
Haben sich miteinander auseinander-
gesetzt und sind noch zusammen.
Mehr denn je frage ich mich,
inwiefern unsere Vorstellung
einer romantischen, ewigen Liebe
lebbar ist.
Und ich ahne, dass wir eingefahrene
Denkweisen verlassen müssten,
wenn wir wirklich lieben
und gemeinsam alt werden wollen.
Dass wir das Besitzdenken überwinden
und uns um einen erweiterten Begriff
von Treue bemühen sollten:
eine Treue, die sich v.a.
als Treue zu sich selbst versteht -
als Ehrlichkeit,
Vertrauen und Freiheit,
die wir einander als Liebende
schenken.